it never stops with these people check
out this headline from the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC this
weekend Ron DeSantis is desperation for
Powers destroying an entire State and
they use the black and white image which
makes it real scary because that gives
it like the the Hitler Hue right just
absolute nonsense uh redhead libertarian
over there on Twitter uh she said she
retweeted it and said Governor DeSantis
you can't sex change for your child in
Florida she worded that a little
strangely and then of course she
retweeted the MSNBC article Elon Musk
saw that and he wrote any parent or
Doctor Who sterilizes a child before
they are a consenting adult should go to
prison for life which by the way is the
law that they just passed here in
Florida and again you must understand to
bring my theory together Elon Musk is an
old school liberal remember that
classical liberal thing I was screaming
about for a long time so now you've got
Piers Morgan you've got Bill Maher
you've got Elon Musk I think we can
throw Joe Rogan into that bucket you
have all of these people and what are
they what is happening to them they are
being alienated by the Democrat Party
they are being alienated by the failure
of liberals to defend liberalism
foreign
[Music]